Lo que vamos a hacer en este video es
pensar cuántos bloques tenemos aquí,
y en lugar de contarlos, los calcularemos usando
la suma. Entonces, ¿cómo lo hacemos? Bueno,
tenemos tres filas aquí: una, dos, tres filas,
y podemos ver claramente que cada una de estas
filas tiene 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 bloques, lo mismo
tenemos aquí en la segunda fila, tenemos: 1, 2,
3, 4, 5 bloques, y lo mismo aquí en esta tercera
fila: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Así que una forma de pensar
sobre la cantidad de bloques que tenemos, es que
tenemos 5 en esta primera fila, entonces tenemos
5 más 5 en la segunda fila son otros cinco, más 5
en la tercera fila -más 5-, así. Si quieres saber
cuántos bloques hay, será lo mismo que 5 + 5 +
5. Ahora, sé lo que piensan algunos de ustedes,
en lugar de pensar en esto sólo en términos de
filas, ¿y si pensáramos en términos de columnas?
Aquí dijimos que tenemos 5 +5 + 5 bloques. Pero
también podríamos pensar que tenemos 5 columnas,
y cada una de esas columnas tiene 3 bloques: esta
es mi primera columna, esta es mi segunda columna,
esta es mi tercera columna, esta es mi cuarta
columna -y ya te estás dando una idea-,
esta es mi quinta columna, y cada una de ellas
tiene 1, 2, 3 bloques, así que esto va a ser
3 más 3 de la segunda columna más 3 de la tercera
columna más 3 de la cuarta columna y finalmente más 3
de la quinta columna. Es interesante que este
número de bloques también se pueda representar
como 3 + 3 + 3 + 3 + 3, ya que como vimos
esto en realidad es lo mismo que 5 + 5 + 5.